we uh got multiple calls at about 8 22
this morning
of a vacant school building that was on
fire
on bridger and 13th street
as soon as the first unit arrived on
scene they called for a second alarm
bringing extra units because of
heavy smoke showing from the roof of the
one story building
as we were arriving on scene there was
squatters
leaving the building they says there's
possibly
some other people inside i think we did
remove one person they weren't injured
we just
more or less assisted them out the fire
was
up above in the attic area not down on
the floor itself
it took them about 15 minutes to bring
it under control
the cause of the fire is under
investigation
but we we know the building is being
frequented it's being used by several
squatters they told us
when we got on the scene that several
people were staying inside that building
it just damaged the park facing 13th
street
the building's been vacant for a while
there's no utilities connected to it
and there were no injuries in connection
with this incident
it's listed in the computer as a saint
joseph's catholic school
[Music]
now i haven't had a chance to look that
up
[Music]
uh the investigators haven't been inside
yet
but it's up above the ceiling on the
roof so
they haven't been up there yet they're
still actually making sure that they got
all the hot spots before the
investigators go up there
that's up the metro you know they have
to see them doing something
uh and a lot of times you you can't
charge those people with arson
because it has to be intentional and
many times
with squatters it's accidental either
smoking cooking
the same thing that people do in their
homes they're staying someplace
for free they're not going to mess that
up by setting it on fire
so a lot of times it's accidental fire
such as smoking and cooking
using candles
they didn't tell us how many people were
there there was two or three here when
we pulled up on scene
i want to lose area we probably will be
here for about another two hours and get
on a side street and open up this main
street
just making sure that the hot spots are
out and letting the investigators do
their investigation
that's it